[Générique] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle, c'est, c'est l'épopée  temporelle
Narrateur: Heureux de vous retrouver chères auditeurs, la dernière fois nous avons découvert que Thomas du futur venait en réalité d'une simulation virtuelle...
...créée par le docteur Simon et maintenant Iris, Eliot et Thomas vont à Rome en -100 avant Jésus-Christ plus précisément au...
...colisée. Hey, je sens que ça va commencer avec le petit lapin...
...qui va disparaître dans la souffrance.
Le lapin : Aïe! Ouille! Je disparais... Putain de merde *pouf*
Thomas: Vous savez ce que ça me rappelle?
- Iris: Laisse moi deviner, un jeu vidéo genre assassin's creed?
Thomas: Non... ça me rappelle quand j'ai visité le colisée de Rome en voyage scolaire en quatrième.
Iris : Ah? Ah bon...
...Ah oui effectivement.
Thomas: Tu sais je suis pas toujours bête.
Iris: Euh oui excuse moi Thomas, tu sais...
Eliot : Là, le robot!
Robot: Encore vous ?!
Thomas: Elle s'en va!
Eliot : Il faut la rattraper!
Thomas: Robot, reviens!
Garde colisée: Vous la! Qui êtes vous? Vous êtes ici pour vous affronter dans l'arêne?!
Thomas: Ouh la...  Non!
Garde colisée : Dans ce cas, on vous jette aux lions.
Iris : Ah ouais, beh alors on est là pour s'affronter dans l'arêne
Garde colisée: J'en étais sûr! Aujourd'hui va être particulièrement sanglant. Suivez moi!
Thomas: Super, on va mourir.
Iris: Mais non on a Thomas du futur qui va pouvoir... Oh merde!...
...c'est vrai, il est plus là, je suis trop conne! On va mourir!
Thomas: Je viens de le dire.
Eliot: J'aurais préféré les lions, ils auraient éprouvé des difficultés à me mâcher.
Thomas: Oh non, le temps va changer, la réalité va être modifiée, le monde va disparaître.
Iris: Ah beh enfin, t'as compris, on va mourir mais t'as compris.
Gladiateur: Hey vous!...
...c'est votre première fois dans le colisée?
Iris : Ouais... voilà
Gladiateur: Ahah, je déconne c'est la première fois pour tout le monde au colisée il ne restera qu'un seul survivant et ce sera moi!
Thomas: Il va faire top 1.
Gladiateur: C'est ça, je vais faire "top 1".
Jules César: Bienvenue au colysée...
...Regardez en haut. Ici. Là... Voilà!
J.C: C'est moi, César, mais vous pouvez m'appeler "Caius Iulius Caesar IV". Vous êtes tous venus pour des combats de gladiateurs...
...Mais vous savez, chaque année ayant obtenu une année bissextile on change les règles...
... et aujourd'hui c'est ma femme qui a choisi: ce sera un concours de talents.
Iris: Un concours de talents? On va peut être rester en vie...
...Thomas c'est quoi ton talent?
Thomas: j'sais pas, dis moi?
Iris: moi j'en sais rien...
Thomas: Ah merde, je croyais que t'avais la réponse...
...j'aurais bien voulu savoir.
J.C: Faites entrer le premier gladiateur!...
...J'ai hâte de voir ce qu'on nous a préparé.
Gladiateur: Caius Iulius Caesar IV voici un petit spectacle de claquettes. Mes enfants adorent quand je le fais à la maison ahahah...
...C'est quoi?!...
... ça marche pas.
J.C: Mmh... Alors ça sonne pas bien du tout. C'est, c'est pouce vers le bas pour moi.
Gladiateur: Non!
J.C: Envoyez les lions!
Gladiateur: Non c'est à cause du sable Caius Iulius Caesar, donnez moi une surface dure et je vous jure que ça revient!...
...Non, non, pas un lion!!
J.C: Gladiateur suivant! J'espère qu'on va un peu plus s'amuser.
Iris:  Oh merde, c'est à mon tour!...
...Olala bon il faut que j'approvise un truc euuh... vous... vous avez quoi sur vous?
Eliot: Du café.
Iris: Non mais je sais mais vous n'avez rien d'autres?!
Thomas: Moi j'ai de la réglisse, un coca, trois bouteilles d'eau, des régalades et des bonbons à la menthe.                                                    Iris: Putain, mais ça sert à rien tout ça.
Thomas: Bon j'avoue, faudrait qu'on lui mette 5 étoiles un moment... J'ai oublié le petit lapin.
Iris: Bon, attends, c'est quoi comme bonbons à la menthe?
Thomas: Des Mentos.
Iris: Super!
Thomas: Tu les veux? J'aime pas ça je les ai pris parce que... c'était gratuit.
Iris: Donne moi ça!
J.C: Jeune femme... Quel est ton talent?
Iris: Regardez bien cette bouteille de coca... enfin... ce-cette bouteille...
...Je vais créer une fontaine magique sous vos yeux ébahis.
J.C: Cette petite femme veut nous faire croire qu'elle peut créer une fontaine avec cette emphore transparente de petite taille...
...pour moi c'est pouces vers le b...
Oh!...
...Oh mais c'est magnifique...
...mais c'est magnifique, regardez cette fontaine marron très spectaculaire, j'achète! C'est pouce en l'air pour moi.
Iris: Merci, merci, merci! Oh c'est pas grand chose!
Iris: Ca va être à vous!
Thomas: Laissez moi un peu de temps, je prépare un truc là! Eliot vas-y...
Eliot:  Très bien j'ai attendu ce moment depuis longtemps.
Thomas: Vraiment?
J.C: Quel accoutrement pour ce nouveau participant malheureusement son armure complète en métal ne sert a rien dans un concours de talents...
...C'est de la musique que j'entends?!
Eliot en rappant: César est beau...
...César est grand, il a érigé l'Italie en plus grand peuple conquérent, il a de l'or dans les *mains* pour nous tous les romains...
...prendre la couronne de lauriers, il a tout tout tout gagné...
... son épée est *la mieux*, son cheval *top soyeux* , de dessous il est radieux et au dessus il n'y a plus que dieu...
...C'est à toi César, je te raconte pas de salade que je donne tout mon amour et cette petite charade...
...Mon premier croisait (?) , mon deuxième est né à Rome et mon tout est le père de tous les hommes... [CESAR]
...dans ma vie au bout du pouce mais tu m'as donné la foi je suis venu dire à tous qu'il n'y a pas plus fort que toi...
...CESAR!.
J.C: J'achète !!...
...Le rythme est bon, les paroles sont sincères, je vais même récupérer le slogan qui sonne super bien...
...César, c'est plus fort que toi!...
...Maintenant, candidat suivant!
Thomas: Mais c'est moi...
Eliot : César, je peux vous faire la danse du robot si vous voulez... Regardez.
J.C : Non, je veux voir le prochain candidat. Les lions ont faim.
Thomas: Oh putain. Bon, j'y vais...
J.C : Jeune homme frêle...
Thomas: Bonjour...
J.C: Quel est ton talent?
Thomas: Euh j'ai préparé un petit passage de stand-up.
J.C: Pardon?
Iris: il veut vous faire rire César...
J.C: Ah, très bien...
Iris : Ok, il est mort
J.C : J'ai hâte de voir ça...
...personne ne m'a fait rire ces 20 dernières années.
Thomas : Alors, je... je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand tu prends le métro, les jolies filles s'assoient jamais à côté de toi.
Iris: Oh putain!
Thomas: Non, ça vous le fait pas?...
...Je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais au starbucks quand tu donnes ton prénom, ils en écrivent un autre...
...Ah merde, merde, c'est des trucs que j'avais remarqué tout seul pourtant.
J.C : Vous ne faites pas rire du tout.
Thomas: J'étais sûr que ça allait faire marrer.
Iris: Mais tente autre chose!
Thomas: ok ok de l'impro euh toi là, tu fais quoi dans la vie?
Esclave: Beh esclave
Thomas: Ouais beh quand tu... tu...
...j'ai pas d'idée merde.
J.C : C'est pas drôle du tout c'est même un poil gênant...
...Ce qui serait drôle, c'est de le voir se faire dévorer. Envoyez les lions!
Iris: Oh non, Thomas!
Thomas: Putain... J'avais noté une autre vanne... Mais...
...C'est quoi ça? Sauvé! C'est mon laser!
Eliot: Thomas, c'est juste un laser qui fait un point rouge.
Thomas: Prenez mon laser dans la face!...
...oh mais putain, ça découpe rien!!!
Iris: Mais on te l'a dit!
Thomas: Qu'est ce qu'il font?! Ils sont cons, ils essaient d'attraper le point rouge...
...quoi?! Allez un peu à gauche...
...un peu à droite...
...Oups, trop à droite, désolé monsieur...
...Maintenant des tours en rond.
J.C: Cet homme contrôle les animaux sauvages, c'est incroyable! Quel talent! C'est étonnant, y'a du peps! J'ACHETE!...
...Pouce en l'air *BOUM*
Iris: Là, le robot!...
...Elle vient d’assommer César!
Thomas: J'ai même pas eu mon pouce en l'air
Robot: Peuple de Rome, ne voyez vous pas que vous êtes manipulé?...
...on vous sert des jeux sanglants pour vous détourner des vrais problèmes.
Iris: Elle veut créer une rébellion.
Robot: Esclave!!...
...Soulevez-vous, Rome vous a tout pris, c'est le moment de récupérer vos droits et d'imaginer un nouvel état! Le votre!...
...Car c'est notre projet!
Iris: Il faut l'arrêter tout de suite!
Thomas: et comment on fait pour nous monter?!
Eliot: Laissez moi faire!
Thomas: pourquoi tu t'allonges sur le ventre Eliot? Tu veux qu'on fasse pareil?
Eliot: Café propulsion!!!
Thomas: Il s'est café-propulsé jusqu'à la madame robot.
Eliot: Toi là! Arrête de modifier le temps, tu vas détruire l'humanité!
Robot: C'est bien le but, on va changer le monde et vous ruinez tous nos efforts!
Eliot: Prends ce café brûlant!
Robot: Tu penses m'arrêter avec un jet de café? Je suis résistante car avant d'être libre, j'étais une machine à café tout comme toi.
Eliot: Vraiment?!
KB29: Je m'appelle KB29 et toi tu sembles être le bon vieux KB28.
Eliot: Mes amis m'appellent : Eliot.
KB29: Tes amis?! Quels amis? Ceux qui te prennent pour une vulgaire machine et n'ont aucun respect pour toi? Ce sont tes maîtres.
Eliot: Je suis *un humain*
KB29: KB28, fait moi un café.
Eliott: Un café robusta dense et profond; avec ou sans sucre?...
...oups.
KB29: Qu'est ce que je disais, tu n'as pas de libre arbitre contrairement à moi. Regarde... Demande moi un café
Eliot: KB29, fait moi un café!
KB29: Non.
Eliot: Oh!
KB29: J'ai entendu tes maîtres te parler, jamais ils ne te considérons comme un des leurs, moi j'ai choisi pour qui je travaille.
Eliot: Mais, ce sont mes amis
KB29: Ah oui? KB28, analyse statistique!
Eliot: Analyse statistique activé.
KB29: Combien de fois t'ont ils demandé un café?
Eliot: *bip bip* 48 fois!
KB29: Combien de fois t'ont-ils dit: Bonjour?
Eliot: Zéro.
KB29: Et combien de fois t'ont-ils pris dans leurs bras?
KB29: c'est pas ce que j'appelle des amis
Iris: Eliot, arrête la!
Eliot: Mais je...
KB29: Encore un ordre, vas-tu faire un choix par toi même?
Eliot: euh
Iris: Mais qu'est-ce que tu attends, bordel? Elle va nous échapper!
KB29: Eliot, viens changer le monde avec moi, à moins que tu préfères leur obéir encore et encore.
Eliot: Iris, Thomas je dois faire mes propres choix. Ne me donnez plus d'ordre, j'ai décidé de suivre KB29.
Iris: Quoi?!
KB29: Tu fais le bon choix, allons-y Eliot.
Iris: Quoi?!...
...Non mais Eliot s'est barré? Oh le connard de traître...
je sais pas qui c'est cette KB29 mais je te jure...
Thomas :  Mais quelque part, si il est plus heureux comme ça, tu sais...
Iris: Mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes?! Il a changé de camp.
Thomas: Ouais c'est vrai, mais je me rends compte que je l'aime vraiment bien et du coup j'ai envie qu'il soit heureux... mais laisse tomber...
...Je dois encore raconter une connerie
Iris: Oui, c'est ça, oui!...
...C'est bien, t'es con mais lucide. ...
...Bon le lapin n'est pas réapparu il faut qu'on arrête la rébellion, fais voir ton laser à la con là...
...Peuple Romain! Ne vous révoltez pas sinon j'envoie le coin rouge magique sur vous et les lions vous mangeront.
Citoyen: On veut la liberté!
Iris: Je comprends très bien et bien commencez par libérer ce petit mouton...
...Voilà, regardez le gambader et maintenant: petit point rouge magique...
...Et voilà! Quelqu'un d'autre veut faire l'expérience?
...Non? Je préfère ça...
...César se réveille, coucou. Vous lui faites un accueil du tonnerre. Compris?!...
...J'ai rien entendu...
...Voilà c'est mieux.
J.C: Oh mais, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?...
...Excusez moi, je me suis endormi, j'ai super mal derrière la tête, y avait une machine qui parle...
...Incroyable...
...Vous êtes prêts pour la suite du concours de talents?!
Le lapin: Ah! Je suis de retour! Merci! Il est ou le bonhomme en métal?
Eris: Il est parti...
Thomas: De son plein gré.
Le lapin: Et c'est à nous de partir! Le docteur Simon a détecté une anomalie en 1962 dans le Massachusetts.
Thomas: Le machin chussets?
Narrateur: Mais non Thomas, le machinchus... le massach... Bon c'est aux States quoi... et je n'en reviens  pas...
...Eliot a fait faux bond et s'est volatilisé avec la méchante KB29. Eh ben on peut faire confiance aux machines.
...et j'ai vu Terminator hn, on sait comment ça se termine...
...A la semaine prochaine pour découvrir ce qu'il se passe au machas...
...Vous avez compris, quoi!
Cyprien: Merci d'avoir écouté et à la semaine prochaine pour la suite de l'épopée temporelle, c'est l'épisode 6.